what do you make of all the ridiculous
is about you and Brad reuniting on all
these carpets all season long its system
that was Jennifer Aniston playing down
the chatter surrounding her and her ex
Brad Pitt it's hysterical
hysterical maybe but then this iconic
moment happened yeah that moment the
moment Brad Pitt and Jennifer Aniston
made our wildest Hollywood dreams come
true proving you can be friends with
your ex listen you got it can't beat
them join them right so it's now et has
an inside look at that friendship 15
years after they announced they were
splitting up all of the rumors are
interesting to me one source tells ET
the two are very good friends adding
neither of them are seeing anyone else
seriously but as of right now they're
just friends brad has grown so much in
his life since he and Jen broke up of
course Brad started dating Angelina
Jolie after they shared the scream in
the 2005 flake a mr. and mrs. Smith do
you think the story's gonna have a happy
ending happy endings easy stories that
connect the two didn't get married until
almost a decade later though in 2014
only two split two years later as for
Jen she tied the knot with Justin
Theroux in 2015 after four years
together so much more special when it's
just your two closest friends and family
and and it's lovely you know where you
want it to be a peaceful environment
want to be active but the two announced
they were splitting up in 2018 a second
source tells et that Brad and Jen
started talking again after their
relationships ended but have only seen
each other occasionally and casually and
our source says Jen has been careful
about being photographed with Brad since
they started getting friendly again to
you know avoid starting rumors I'm a
tabloid nightmare like people that my
life seems so much more dramatic and
interesting than it is just because of
the tabloids the first source tells ET
quote right now they just love and adore
each other and have been much closer
friends since their divorces they have a
very mature relationship that has
evolved over time because they both have
experienced marriages that didn't work
out and the second source also says brad
has apologized to Jen for some of the
things that went down in the past noting
that brad is completely sober now and in
a different place than when he and Jen
were a couple and get this our source
says brad has taken ownership for his
past mistakes which has made his
friendship with Jen possible today as
for all the media attention the source
says they have both laughed a bit about
it and a third source explains that we
shouldn't read into their friendship too
much saying it's been nothing more than
fun run-ins ok the obsession the world
the internet everyone is waiting they're
hoping for this moment where you and
Jennifer run into each other so they can
take their picture she's a good friend
so they can you know how this goes the
second the second most important reunion
every of her year you know how that
works play on friends and then they were
saying that anyways I am living for all
this Brad and Jen friendship stuff who's
with me
just me no I know you are too of course
you can count on et to bring you all the
latest on these friendly exes so make
sure to keep it locked right here until
next time I'm Holly Stephens see you
soon
[Music]